كنا لنكتفي لو عرفنا الاجابه ولو على بعض
هذه الاسئله استحاله الوصول الى الكل
اوصلتنا الى القليل منهم الى حيث محمود
شاب يعيش ربيع العشرين وفي قصته رساله لكل
انسان
[موسيقى]
مرقت بمراحل الخمس تعيد قبل الرسمه مثل ما
هي ما تركت مرحله ما مرقت فيها
واتمنى النكران
انه انا لا لا ابني ما معه توحد لا ابني
ما معه شي هيدي مرحله وبتمرق بتعرفي كيف
بتضحك على حالها يعني وبتتخبى وراء اصبعها
بعدين مرحله الغضب بعد مرحله الغضب انه
ليش هو عم بيتفاعل معي ليش محمود هو معه
توحد
مع العلم انه ولا مره سالت حالي او سالت
رب العالمين انه ليش انا
كنت انا صغير
كان بابا يغني لي بالفورد شو بحبك لما
بتحكي شو بحبك لما بتحكي ترسم شفافك ضحكي
شو بحبك لما بتبكي وعم بتغلغل فيه حبيبي
انت الاحلام عمري
وفي بعض الاحيان فكرت بالانتحار
بعض الاحيان كنت اتمنى الموت انا وابني
لانه انا موتي انا ما رح يجيب نتيجه
بالنهايه ابن الحيضل لحاله وهيدا مش الشي
اللي انا بدي اياه
فانا لما حسيت اني انا خلاص ذقت ودرعا
بيقولوا خلص ما عاد بقى قادره اتحمل هيدي
الفاتن النكديه والاكتئاب والحزن
بلشت بقى
ابحث عن حلول نفسيه فرحت درست سايكو دراما
لانه انا كنت مقتنعه انه انا مش رح يمشي
حالي بجلسه وجلستين ولا سنه وسنتين انا
مقتنعه انه انا بحاجه اني انا اعرف كيف
اتعامل مع مشاعري وافهم نفسيتي
لكل العمر لانه انا عارفه الوضع اللي انا
فيه حيرافقني كل العمر
حلو حبيبي شو حلو
هالقمر شوفوا ما اجمله بس انا عبالي دلل
وحياتي ما حدا بقى يزعلوا